and it is david price his third start in
a bullpen game last time he had one of
these last thursday against san
francisco perfect over two and two
thirds and he struck out five he really
is coming out of the bullpen like his cy
young year when he was a starter of
course with david price he sets the tone
and he has been doing it very well late
night baseball as tommy edmond digs in
against david price
edmond with a drive
left center well hit and off the wall
tommy edmond on his way to second base
standing up with a lead-off double
back-to-back game starting things with a
double for tommy edmond dylan carlson
off the end of the bad base heading to
right tommy edmond racing around third
and he's held up and runners at the
corners he had to make sure that got
through the infield it did it's kind of
like he just last second said i'm just
gonna flip it out there in steps paul
goldschmidt
3-2
hit out to left that's trouble netball
down a ground rule double for paul
goldsmith the first three have reached
here in the first and the cardinals have
an early one-nothing lead what a chance
here for yadier molina in a 3-2 pitch
price to yachty he's got carlson a third
goldschmidt at second another 3-2 and
price hits him down with a fastball a
big out number two for david price
another fastball with a lot of the
strike zone but he gets it by him that
is a huge out he can get out of this
with only one run facing a hot hitter
here though tyler o'neill another home
run last night
price is ready and here's his 0-2 pitch
he's [ __ ]
took him 29 pitches but he's able to get
out of it with just the one run
what an odd season it's been in many
ways for john gant
4-3 the record a 1-8-1
era despite the fact he has 31 walks
and 35 strikeouts 31 walks from gant
he's always pitching it seems like
with runners on spooky bets he was on
base four times last night
the 2-2 is swung on in man
nasty change-up by john gant and the
first out here's max muncie 20-game on
base three for muncie that's a walk on
base extended 21 games and they have
their first base runner
there's justin turner you know what he
does
as good as anyone i've ever seen is stay
back
back double play ball potentially the
turn it's a double play as edmond got
taken out at second base
runners on no problem for john gantz
turn two it's one nothing one nothing
game as we move along to the second
david price back out there to face sosa
rondon and gant have a little easier
second inning he hopes bounces on that
one and gets sosa
price is 3-2
this is high and away his first walk and
a one out base runner here in the second
sacrifice situation for john gant out in
front of the plate but that's foul and
so that'll go down as a strikeout for
price in his third tonight here's tommy
edmund doubled his first time up work
the count off the wall in left center
and has scored the only run tonight
up the middle tommy edmond two for two
rondon
from first to third like to see that as
well it's a great job right there you
can just see just a little effort right
there by rondon
doesn't even draw a throw
ball's hit pretty good gets up the
middle he's going hard the whole way and
look how hard he's running he's running
a little bit on the play but can't throw
that ball to third base because you know
tommy edmond will keep on running i
would imagine dave roberts one way or
another this is price's last batter
potentially now you have goldschmidt on
deck but he's now at 47 pitches we'll
see runners at the corners and the
one-two hit the other way in a base hit
two-nothing cardinals
carlson and rbi single on one and two
and edmond the third love seeing that
first to third twice in this inning
partially good piece of hitting and
partial luck but just putting this ball
in play and you can see he's trying to
hit that ball the other way that's the
only thing you can do he's beat and so
that will do it for david price joe
kelly coming on with runners at first
and third and two out
of just prevent the damage yeah this
right now is it's gotten off to a bad
start for the dodgers there's a bad tone
to the game but you can all of a sudden
change the tone in a hurry joe kelly and
get the offense going but first and
third two out
get the out get him in the dugout
two-nothing st louis two on two out and
the hitter is goldschmidt two balls two
strikes two out swung on and missed
strike three and that will end the
inning goldsmith down on strike will
smith to lead off the second for the
dodgers against john gant two-two
crack bad flare in the right lead off
base it will smith giving the cardinals
some of their own soft contact medicine
there first hit of the game for la comes
from will smith will smith behind the
plate when david price is out there and
carlson was dropping a few in he's in
center field we'll drop this one in
front of rundown
three and two to chris taylor one out
smith stays put there's a line drive
face hitting the left field
chris taylor continues his hot hitting a
clean hard hit line drive to left first
and second one out pujols coming up boy
he hits the ball hard and it brings up
one of the all-time great st louis
cardinals albert pujols teammate of his
and yadier molina albert spent a lot of
time on the st louis side when they were
stretching the day kind of
reunion of sorts with a lot of guys
got here in his 18th season albert in
his 21st
waiting on a 1-2 from gantt
tapper left side
arnado
smith the third taylor to second
two gun
there's baity
one two
round by the first backs up goldschmidt
again to the bag in time to get beatty
and andy inning dodgers leave him at
second and third and trailed two nothing
after two lena who struck out his first
time 2-2
strikes him out 99 to the knees to go
and an 0-2 from joe kelly o'neal
swings and misses strike three
back-to-back case and a one two three
third for kelly back to the top and
mookie bets
a one-out walk that's another base
runner against gant and this is kind of
what he does four base runners now
through two plus one thing about john
gant
you saw it a bunch last year with a good
sinker good change up get guys out in
front and you see a lot of ground balls
and the potential of a double play
trying to keep an eye on that's here
there's your ground ball
out there the turn double play the
second the cardinals have turned tonight
bickford into the game bottom third of
the cardinals order sosa rondon and gan
sosa tries to check his swing but can't
and bickford with his strikeouts open
the fourth
pickford with a one two three inning
bookend strikeouts smith a double play
candidate here
2-2 pitch to will smith
and he struck him out
on the outside corner
second strikeout for gann i mean are we
really watching this like this guy out
of the wind-up ball one walk comes in
the stretch
strike one
strikeout matt beatty grounded out to
first with two runners on his first time
up
outside corner struck him out and the
third strikeout for gantt no argument
from beatty we'll go to the bottom of
the six second and third two outs and
gavin lux is up representing the
go-ahead run
lux breaks his bat
shallow right center sliding catch he
caught it he caught it dylan carlson
what a great play by dylan karlsson
leaving two on
he's grounded out and he's been struck
out two
[Applause]
is
nothing
matt beatty with his third home run of
the year we're all leaving deuces wide
some anger into that ball
we head to the ninth golden base runner
and scoring position now emundo sosa
hasn't done anything at the plate so far
in the series here's a one-two pitch
sosa puts it in play base heading
here comes o'neil he will score and the
cardinals have taken the lead three to
two here in the ninth and sosa winds up
at second what a great play
by sosa right there not just getting the
hit
but
going to second base first and second
two out and mookie bets coming up
dodgers have not had a walk off win this
season
out to left o'neal back he got it
tyler o'neal with the catch up against
the wall and the cardinals win it three
to two and what a play by o'neal to
finish off game two